[Music]
swedish activists greta thundberg and
other young environmentalists attending
a climate conference in milan have won a
seat at the table meeting with italy's
prime minister mario draghi there is no
planet b
there is no plan their audience with a
g7 leader comes two days after
thunberg's scathing criticism that
politicians weren't acting with urgency
to solve the climate crisis your
pressure is very welcome
we need to be whipped into action
your mobilization
has been powerful and rest assured
we are listening
hundreds of young environmentalists from
around the world gathered here to
propose climate solutions directly to
global leaders ahead of the cop 26
summit taking place in scotland in
november
world leaders beamed in as did the pope
to give their backing
the delegates are calling for the
elimination of all fossil fuels by 2030
a more transparent and equal climate
finance system and climate education for
global youth
their proposals will be considered in
the next few days at a pre-cop meeting
here in milan ahead of the scotland
summit this is only going to be
meaningful if the things that are
changing in governments right now
reflect what we are saying because that
never happens the process should be with
us and for us not just for us because
the process that is just for us does not
include us at all
[Music]
dozens of protesters outside the
perimeter briefly blocked traffic before
police dispersed them
the delegates found an ally in italy's
first minister for ecological transition
who shares a key vision of theirs
this is exactly what greta marissa
together said if we put together the
social inequality global level and the
climate change emergency we have to
treat those together otherwise we simply
fix the
the climate problem but then we have
millions of people losing the job
the name youth for climate can be seen
as just a branding mechanism but veteran
attendees of global environmental
summits tell us by focusing on young
people's ideas this conference is
actually injecting a sense of optimism
and urgency sometimes lacking at such
meetings
they don't have the baggage that a lot
of other people have right so they have
the enthusiasm maybe the in the navy
of uh wanted to change the world i think
that's an essential ingredient other
activists the activists aren't so naive
though to believe everything they're
told and will turn up the pressure if
leaders don't deliver on promises made
here adam rainey al jazeera milan
let's bring in assad remin in london
he's a spokesman for the comp 26
coalition the climate justice movement
good to have you with us
what do you make of the comments you
heard there right at the end of that
report uh that young people have the
naivety
to want to change the world our
government's really going to listen to
them or is this just uh about making it
look as though they will
unfortunately the truth is ministers
will happily pull for pictures with
young climate activists they'll be
politely listening to their proposals
but when they actually sit down for
their meeting they'll be in those
demands and go back to his business as
usual ignoring just not just them but
the millions of people around the world
who are calling for climate justice and
it's not been a lack of proposals in
fact we could fill that conference hall
three times over with the countless
policy papers and demands for urgent
action that civil society have tabled
over decades unfortunately what we see
at this moment is tough talk but empty
promises to act by governments and none
of that is stopping us from spiraling
towards a catastrophic warming that
scientists are warning us about you had
greta the clip from greta and as greta
said a couple of days ago we've had 30
years of blah blah blah 30 years of
broken promises and i predict ministers
will
when they end this pre-cup we'll promise
to build that better to deal with the
climate crisis and the crisis of poverty
inequality but that will unfortunately
be just more blah blah blah but are
young people
being naive in their demands
of course they're not being naive look
the global scientists have issued a code
red for humanity they've said that the
window to act is rapidly closing the un
itself has said the current proposals on
the table to cut emissions are simply
too weak and unfair the richest
countries need to cut their emissions by
2030 to prevent a breach of the critical
1.5 degree guard rail yet they're
kicking action down the road to 2050 and
they're leaving us on a course for three
degrees warming the un said we need at
least one and a half trillion dollars a
year for a global green new deal so you
can tackle climate and inequality and
that the poorest aren't left behind yet
rich countries haven't even met the
promise of 100 billion that they made a
decade ago frankly it's not that they
don't know what actually needed it's
that they're still acting to protect
profits of big polluting companies
rather than listening to their citizens
and it's not naive from young people
they are actually speaking trees to
power all right so mario draghi is right
when he says the politicians need to be
whipped into action
absolutely and you know the un secretary
general said it's your solidarity
demands for action that set a powerful
example that's absolutely true but we
all know that we've been taking to the
street and building power um and they've
not been listening to us and that's why
young youth movements and global civil
society are on november 6 we'll do a
massive global day of action for climate
justice because we know it's only us
that can change the outcome of both the
cup 26 summit and to give real hope to
humanity all right so what are the
prospects for cop 26 are you optimistic
unfortunately not so i mean what we what
is needed both in terms of the emission
reductions the finance on the table
their support for poorer countries we're
far far off what is needed rich
countries are still dragging their heels
we've added a lot yes
lots of warm words but climate science
tells us winning slowly is the same as
losing and we're not seeing the either
the urgency we're not seeing the
ambition and we're not seeing the
fairness from rich countries and they
really need to step up and take the
action that is needed we need to
transform our energy systems transform
our food systems we need to tackle
global inequality we're in the midst of
a corvid pandemic which has further
exposed all of the inequalities and
injustices that exist within societies
and between rich and poorer countries
but it doesn't have to be like this we
know what needs to be done we have the
policies in we have the policies we have
the technology what is lacking is the
political will really good to talk to
you i said many things indeed i said
remnant there
in london